نحن هنا على مشارفي بلده مترو فيتش
الشماليه كوسوفو التي شهدت مع بلدات اخرى
محيطه بها توترات خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
بسبب الاحتجاجات التي نفذتها الاقليه
الصربيه ضد قرارات اتخذتها حكومه بريشتينا
الكوسوفي نشاهدنا هؤلاء الجنود التابعين
لقوات حفظ السلام التي يقودها حلف شمال
الاطلسي وهم يزيلون اخر الحواجز التي
نصبها الناشطون السر خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه هذه الشاحنه المحترقه التي تتم
ازالتها الان من هذه العربه التي يقودها
جندي سويسري
جنود من دول اعضاء في النيته وغير اعضاء
ايضا مثل سويسرا ازيل هذا
الحاجز الاخيره بما ينهي المظاهر
الميدانيه التوترات التي شهدتها هذه
المناطق خلال شهر ديسمبر وقبل ذلك حقيقه
قرارات تغيير لوحات السيارات وبطاقات
الهويه واجراء انتخابات محليه في هذه
البلدات التي تقطنها اغلبيه سربيه رفضت من
قبل هذه الاغلبيه تقول حكومه كوسوفي ان
هذه الاقليه الصربيه تتبع تعليمات
تيليجرام
لا تعلي المصلحه الوطنيه وهناك الكثير من
المناشدات من عواصم غربيه تحديدا من
بروكسل واشنطن بخلق باجواء مؤته
للحوار وانهاء هذا التصيد بشكل نهائي من
خلال تسويه سياسيه محمد المدهون الجزيره
من بلده مترو فيتشا الشماليه